serious consequences that's what the eu
says the uk would face if it triggers
article 16. it followed a meeting
between the two sides on thursday over
the northern ireland protocol
article 16 could suspend the protocol
and lead to retaliation possibly new
tariffs and that could spiral into an
all-out trade war so just how damaging
would that be for businesses on either
side of the channel
tom parker is president of the british
chamber of commerce in the eu and joins
me live from brussels good morning mr
parker
good morning
um
how cross are european leaders about the
stance taken by lord frost and the
uk government
well the position of eu leaders is one
that's been
evolving for some time now
the uk has expressed uh
the right or or has uh indicated that it
would be prepared to take serious
measures
i.e trigger article 16 for some time now
so there has been uh concern and uh
significant discussion about the
implication of this and what the eu
might do in turn should indeed article
16 be triggered uh the eu has different
options on the table and that's subject
to quite some discussion and debate
well uh when you say the eu has
different options on the table how
serious might those options be i mean
we're hearing a talk here
that um our government might invoke
article 16. i mean how hot could this
become
well i mean if the the uk were to
trigger article 16 i think that one
option that the eu has discussed or at
least certain member states have put
forward would be to basically terminate
the the trade and corporation agreement
the tca
that would be if you like the the
nuclear option
um other options available to them could
be that they they put tariffs on certain
products uh that the uk are exporting
they could take steps to
make trade practically more complicated
by for example stepping up controls on
uh you know goods that are exported out
of the uk and even products going into
the uk to basically create you know a
big uh
blockage at the ports and then you'd
have problems with supply and supply
chain obviously going into uh you know
the christmas period which uh you know
would be damaging for everybody
when we say damaging uh are we talking
about an annoyance or are we talking
about something
much bigger than that
i think we're talking about something
much bigger than that i mean we've seen
already the practicalities of brexit in
terms of moving good uh you know uh
back and forth um and uh this has become
something of an issue now of course
we've had the the the covert situation
which has had muddied the waters to a
certain extent but i think no doubt
already some of the challenges that are
being had are brexit related
and
you know i think you would see certainly
a major step up of that it doesn't take
very much at the ports
by way of a slow down a couple of
minutes can lead to
significant uh delays and
tailbacks on the roads so it could be
major
how likely do you think that there is
going to be
a serious problem and let's measure it
this way
that um
people are even now beginning to buy
their christmas presents for their
children they're thinking about
what they're going to
give
each other at christmas what uh
decorations all the rest of it
do you think that we are going to see
christmas interrupted in any serious way
because of this
looming dispute
it's it trevor is difficult to say i
mean we're obviously in a highly
political situation and and all sides
will be weighing that up
and you know i think that
the consequences of this are potentially
major to go into the end of year period
with that consequence you know i i know
that that will be something at front of
mind for politicians on both sides um
but i'm afraid it's not not to be ruled
out and unfortunately you know the
people who are going to end up paying
the price for this
are you know normal people like us and
the businesses that get caught in the
crossfire who are trying to to trade
normally but are finding themselves in
in difficulties and even greater
difficulty um than they have over the
course of the of the past couple of
years
the prime minister and lord frost would
say that they are being
resolute they're standing up for britain
they are trying to
uh exercise the spirit of the agreement
we have now left the eu and so on and so
forth
how do you think they've handled this
have they done the right thing or do you
think this is uh
that the tactically they're making some
errors
um well the position of the british
chamber of commerce in in uh
belgium and to the eu is that we
wouldn't want to see
either side trigger article 16 um unless
there were really very exceptional
circumstances and and you know obviously
northern ireland is a hugely complicated
issue it is not for the british chamber
of commerce uh in belgium and to the eu
to comment on that you know we don't
have that knowledge or expertise but we
believe that uh at this instance article
16 is something that as i say is a
measure of last resort and
there's no doubt that if it is triggered
it is going to cause immediate
problems it's going to cause significant
economic damage and in the long term
it's going to further break break down
trust so you know our view is the
negotiations must continue
these
really major major issues of importance
to all sides and we would very strongly
encourage negotiators on on all sides to
find an alternative solution
tom parker thank you so much
thank you